une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de scorvic nos invités
[Musique]
du podcast au Québec un des fondateurs
des pères fondateurs devrais-je dire
dans le monde podcast une personne
importante dans le monde de l'humour
aussi vraiment en fait Michel grenier
qui est comme quand tu penses à
un gérant d'humour au Québec tu penses à
Michel grenier c'est le gérant de Mike
word de son frère Daniel de grenier
c'est le gérant de Pierre-Yves
redémarrer et de d'autres puis c'est un
gars qui est un invité de podcast par
excellence parce que c'est un gars qui
pose une question il part puis c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment fascinant de
savoir du raconter plein d'affaires
comment qui a rencontré Mike comment que
ça a commencé tout ça on a parlé mais
beaucoup du podcast le futur du podcast
ou ça s'en va comment ça fonctionne un
peu des dessous du podcast on a parlé de
des de Mike avec des sous-écoutes avec
l'idea
là-dessus sa vision de Dieu
c'était vraiment super généreux de son
temps de ces idées même il t'arrive ici
il a compris essayer ça
c'est vraiment un honneur de le recevoir
Michel grenier on a parlé un petit peu
aussi une anecdote qui me restait
longtemps de publicité vous allez voir
Michel raconte une anecdote dans
laquelle lui puis Marie qui ont refusé
une une pub et c'est probablement un des
grands y de la société québécoise où
est-ce qu'on a pris une direction pour
la société au complet aurait pris une
autre direction s'il y avait dit oui
cette opportunité la réalité parallèle
où est-ce qu'il y aurait dit oui à ça on
verra dans un autre monde complètement
dans une civilisation soit extrêmement
plus avancé ou vraiment encore
Néandertal ça aurait été souvent la fin
de la civilisation
super belle conversation super cool Guy
bon podcast bon écoute le podcast de
cette semaine est présenté par nos amis
chez manscape qui sont avec nous depuis
le début et qui n'arrêtent pas de lancer
des nouvelles gammes de produits de
nouveaux paquets absolument incroyable
notamment celui-là pour la barbe d'homme
toi tu as une moustache en ce moment
mais semi moustache souvent je
rafraîchis
pour justifier moustache devient juste
un peu trop longue tu bois ton verre de
lait là
si tu veux pas ça moi je me rappelle
quand je vais laisser pousser la
moustache trop longtemps quand je
faisais de la natation je prenais
toujours deux gorgées galeries une
première gorgée avec mon gadrive puis
après ça je me léchais les babines pour
avoir la deuxième gorge
c'est c'est ça peut être intéressant
mais en général c'est peu souhaitable
maintenant ta clé j'ai juste comme avec
mon
découper ma moustache à la perfection
puis c'est vraiment le meilleur outil en
fait pour tout ce qui est pilosité
faciale puis avoir la longueur désirée
avoir
parce que en fait au lieu d'avoir des
affaires qui se rajoutent dessus au
titre d'habitude tu arrives avec deux ou
trois choix de grandeur mais ici il y a
20 choix de grandeur en fait de 0.5
jusqu'à 10 puis ça ça permet vraiment
une personnalisation une grande
personnalisation de la longueur de votre
barbe moi je suis fort du GOTY si j'ai
un bon côté quand même un bon moustache
puis un bang communément appelé le bang
fait que j'ai décidé d'aller vraiment en
ligne dans le bang ce que je fais c'est
que je me mets à trois sur les joues et
après ça je me mets à 7 sur le bains
Chris
ça fait que à chaque fois que je fais ça
j'ai quand même le beigne idéal ben que
je souhaiterais avoir en fait le même
que tout le monde essentiellement
devrait souhaiter avoir bref protèle à
moins que tu ailles aux choses à dire
sur toute le paquet qui est ici qui est
là c'est que ça vient tu es avec un kit
au complet tu sais on pourrait passer
une heure avec passion mais bref il y a
aussi il y a un shampoing il y a une
crème il y a un peigne de brosse qui a
des ciseaux il y a tout ce qu'il faut
pour avoir la barbe la moustache tout ce
que vous voulez dans le visage idéal
donc si vous voulez y aller pour offrir
ce kit là ou n'importe quel kit de
domaine ski que vous entendez parler
depuis des années maintenant utiliser le
code promo sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et la livraison gratuite puis
vous allez pas le regretter je vous le
dis fait merci man's skate et Merci à
VOUS d'encourager le sans fil podcast
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des podcasts on dirait que c'est
niaiseux mais quand
ça fait longtemps quand même qu'on fait
sous-écoute ça fait quand même longtemps
mais je te dirai que depuis 2016 c'est
là que j'ai commencé à en écouter plus
parce que c'est super simple mais c'est
les
juste francophone mais quand vient le
temps d'écouteur en anglais j'écoute de
la faute sur de la photographie ah ouais
hein ouais des podcasts de photos ouais
c'est bizarre parce que on parle d'image
dans un médium qu'on voit pas d'image tu
as quelque chose technique genre
critique de nouveaux appareils qui
viennent de sortir toutes sortes de
choses comme ça fait que c'est super
intéressant il fait combien de temps que
tu fais la photo aussi ça fait je te
dirai du bureau 14h attends c'est pas si
longtemps que ça c'est juste que
demander je me suis mis à
essayer de comprendre si ta [__] là je
m'amuse au bout là
c'est si tu peux apprendre à l'infini et
puis au début on dirait que le gars qui
ping est comme vraiment élevé là pour
rentrer dans seul ça peut paraître
vraiment comme immense acheter un
appareil photo pour faire des photos en
action de sport puis comme quand
j'essaie de comprendre
j'ai un bon appareil dans mes mains mais
j'ai pas du tout la connaissance pour
être capable de maximiser le fait que je
fais des photos correctes avec un
institut bombe mais ce qu'il faut par
exemple aujourd'hui le fait de plus être
en argentique pour les gens qui nous
écoutent l'argentique c'est sur film en
fait le fait si tu fais ta photo de
sport
je rentre d'une salle chez des gens
c'est ok je vais me mettre à ça je suis
un plateau
[Musique]
pose des oiseaux pas sûr que les oiseaux
vont être mais je pense que oui le type
mais justement
mon mon appareil quand je l'ai acheté
moi je pensais que c'était comme once
fait ça
je suis tombé dans les lentilles donc
là j'ai compris qu'il y avait un autre
cache à comprendre sur les lentilles de
photos non parce que tu peux tu
t'achètes toujours des bonnes lentilles
parce que les boîtiers vont toujours
évoluer mais une bonne lentille ça reste
une bonne lentille il y a encore des
photographes aujourd'hui qui prennent
des lentilles des 50 ans s'amuse à faire
des affaires
des bons verres ça va toujours rester
roulant
dans le fond j'utilise pratiquement
toujours les deux ou trois même
lentilles mais on dirait que j'aimais
le photographe officiel du milieu de
l'humour exactement dans une photo de
Michel grignotte avec les crédits merci
Michel grenier pour la photo
j'ai beaucoup d'artistes ça me fait rire
il y a beaucoup sur ton humour qui font
comment j'ai une photo c'est son
comptant d'avoir une photo c'est drôle
parce que c'est les artistes qui ont pas
encore l'argent pour se faire un
photoshoot tout ça des fois je regarde
sur leurs affiches quand ils vont jouer
puis c'est mes photos à moi je trouve ça
drôle
j'aime bien grosse à travers
changer complètement de sujet là pour
parler un petit peu de sous-écoute là à
travers ça fait vraiment longtemps on en
parlait quand on s'est vu parce qu'on
s'est vu dernièrement au festival de la
musique
radio numérique éphémen
puis tu on en parlait comment sous
écoute ça fait ça fait longtemps puis
que ça a commencé sur des laptop puis
sur des webcam puis le s'est rendu
évidemment ce qu'on connaît du podcast
live avec le plus de de spectateurs
est-ce que
à travers tout ça c'est le projet qui
commence comme un projet de coeur
évidemment on en parle pas de revenus
liés à ça au début jusqu'à maintenant
probablement le podcast le plus créatif
au Québec est-ce que le cœur est encore
haut et oui oui non
c'est même l'argent je te dirai tu vois
on va le faire à Toronto pour nous faire
rire mais ça nous coûte l'argent des
lots
c'est de long ça va dans deux trois
semaines je sais pas quand est-ce que le
podcast va sortir mes fin juin 2023 on
s'en bat Paris Lausanne Bruxelles on
finit à Cannes
c'est tellement drôle ça fait aucun sens
bon quand j'ai entendu le pitch pour ça
je vais encore aller dans un Bolos mais
j'ai un chat on le fait let's
il y a beaucoup d'affaires
il y a une phrase qui est importante
c'est peu importe ce que tu fais dans la
vie là c'était passionné de ce que tu
fais ça va le devenir payant est-ce que
c'est payant oui c'est faut juger du
premier janvier au 31 décembre est-ce
que c'est payant oui mais est-ce qu'elle
est à Toronto 2 jours couché avec 8 gars
pour jouer d'une salle de ça c'est
payant non c'est ça faut faut que tu
calcules sur l'année les autres on a du
fun à faire ça c'est des belles
rencontres c'est des gens on a du
plaisir c'est
c'est je travaille pour mon avis petit
mind peu importe le long on parle de
sous-écoute mais je fais de la gérance
d'artiste depuis quasiment 30 ans moi
depuis Mike fait 29 ans qu'on se connaît
tu sais ça fait ça on est des vieilles
personnes dans le sens que il y a
quelque chose qui nous tente et on le
fait on sait jamais été l'argent qui
nous a motivé faut pas que vous soyez
c'est ça qui est bizarre si c'était pas
motivé par l'argent tu vas en faire mais
si tu veux rien faire de l'argent tu vas
en faire aussi mais tu vas peut-être
oublier d'autres choses à
des affaires mais c'est seulement qu'il
y a juste animé c'est sûr qu'on se
console tout le temps c'est au mic me
disait j'aimerais avoir telle personne
dans les deux dernières années on a un
peu changé la façon de bouquet
sous-écoute c'est ça aussi c'est la
force d'un projet c'est de trouver la
motivation de se renouveler ouais nous
tu me dis de faire sous écoute ben non
on se renouvelle à chaque année tu sais
2015 on a sorti d'un appart pour aller
avec des GoPro pour aller au bordel avec
des petites caméras Sony ça c'est en
2015 par 2019 mais on a changé de salle
puis de 2020 2022 c'était à pandémie
fait qu'on essaie de faire des podcasts
avec des plexiglas puis faire des
podcasts sur zoom ces affaires
on a eu tout le temps puis dans la
depuis qu'on est revenu de la pandémie
ce que sous écoute a décidé de prendre
comme tangente c'est mettons Mike il me
dit ah j'ai croisé mes tons clos meunier
dans
choisi dans les 5 ce qui fait mais je
veux que la personne vienne avec
quelqu'un qui est tellement à l'aise
par business c'est parce que des bons
invités de podcast il y en a pas tant
que ça c'est un bon invité de podcast
c'est quelqu'un qui est intéressant mais
qui essaye pas d'intéressant c'est
quelqu'un qui est drôle mais qui essaye
pas d'être drôle c'est quelqu'un aussi
qui t'en donne jus c'est quelqu'un qui
sent pas outré de Jersey ayant du pénis
on peut pas c'est quelqu'un qui va être
capable de t'en donner s'il faut parler
de pénis l'ombre en parler s'il faut
parler de podcast on va en parler s'il
faut parler de lutte bon on va José de
lutte tu comprends mais faut parler de
faut être ouvert à parler tout puis
passer que la balle tombe c'est souvent
tu as des invités c'est oui non oui
des épisodes faut travailler fort et
vous êtes comme comme l'autre
aujourd'hui
ouais petit papa on l'entend vite hein
dans les réponses des invités quand ça
quand il y a un point afin des phrases
tu sais quand tu entends un invité un
bon invité de podcast il y aura vraiment
des points que tu vois pas venir mais un
invité moins bon un petit peu qui est
moins bien à parler devant les gens des
fois il arrive avec un point dans sa
phrase que tu comme je viens de faire là
pour pas que la balle tombe on joue
ensemble c'est pour les Waiki ou à
quelque chose faut pas que la balle
tombe mais Mike et il est incroyable
pour ceux quand les invités ont fini
leur affaire il est capable de juste
tomber en mode je voulais parler de ça
justement fait qu'on report sur ce pied
qui se prépare 0 puis aussi c'est Mike
il y a un autre affaire aussi en podcast
c'est que Mike ça a été dérange pas un
blanc
ça il va prendre ça va arriver des fois
si je vous écoute il y a des 4 secondes
450 fois par épisode
des fois il rattrape même des moments
des gens de j'ai pas de quelqu'un faire
un gag ça lève pas vraiment puis le lui
veut juste acheter une petite affaire
plus finalement enfin qui est vraiment
il est vraiment fort vraiment incroyable
c'est Mike il y a une certaine force
puis et c'est aussi Mike il s'est il a
travaillé fort pour le terrain de jeu
qui aujourd'hui c'est avec la liberté
qu'il y a ne veut pas dire tu peux pas
faire du du Minecraft
[Musique]
un niveau donc ça fait que les invités
ils viennent dans Cours hamac qui fait
ah ouais tu as cette grève pour jouer
toi les invités montent d'une coche là
tu fais comment ça je l'ai jamais vu de
même cette invité là parce qu'il est
encore à mec ou est-ce qu'il y a 100
personnes il y ait pu c'est souvent la
télévision c'est juste aujourd'hui dans
la façon que on prépare les podcasts il
y a tellement il y a cette espèce de
liberté-là peu importe le podcast ça
devient une certaine liberté c'est comme
aujourd'hui mais on fait le podcast bon
premièrement ton gilet son étant allé il
marche pas ça tu es d'accord en partant
tu me suis toutes les marques qu'on peut
reconnaître ça marche pour ça
il y a tout le temps des détails c'est
pour l'heure d'arriver j'aurais eu tant
de personnes qui se passe le podcast
c'est une liberté totale je pense c'est
ça qui attire un peu les gens enfin j'ai
l'impression que pitié on a quand même
évidemment on n'a pas le la la durée de
sous-écoute en terme de dans les années
là tu sais mais on a quand même 4 plus
que 4 ans de poker
au début ça m'a paraissait comme
vraiment ça puis on dirait que on dirait
que ça a la shifté un petit peu puis je
trouve ça vraiment c'est pour ça que je
trouve encore plus
fou sous écoute fou étant le pire
adjectif j'aurais pu trouver mais je
trouve que sous écoute ça a vraiment
comme c'est resté 100% fruit puis on
dirait que le monde qui sont à la
recherche de
Marc à gratter mettons et ont juste
laissé sous écoute de côté ouais
genre on peut plus et tout on peut plus
relever toutes les affaires qui se
disent la boxe sont comme choix
choquantes ou tu sais révérencieuse
mettons ils ont juste fait c'est comme
c'est une liberté
qui a été comme accepté sous écoute ça
ça se dit ouais ça se fait mais qu'on le
ferait pas nécessairement ailleurs mais
c'est comme sous écoute aux autres je
peux ils peuvent aller là sauf que la
raison pourquoi qu'on peut aller là
c'est parce qu'au terme qui est adorait
puis les gens qui l'aillent puis qui
chialaient il écoute pas c'est ça tandis
que moi je tombe sur votre podcast c'est
les chiffres c'est un beau podcast je
vous reconnais
comme les gens ils vont tomber entre les
podcasts allez remarquer toutes les gens
qui écoutent des podcasts à la maison
souvent vous êtes là puis vous cliquez
maintenant je clique sur le vol va me
référer à autre chose mais si je vois my
world dans le choix lui je l'aime pas
Thierry des handicapés mais parfait
écoute les pots mais moi tu me fais une
faveur en écoutant moi parce que c'est
genre de trucs qui appellerait que les
gens qui écoutent sous écoute
comprennent le décorum qu'on prenne que
c'est pour rire là c'est Max promène pas
dans la rue puis il y a un courage
mais peu importe qui parle dans son
podcast il y a une différence entre
l'artiste fait sur scène et fait or 5 et
là tout est là dedans je pense les gens
qui écoutent sous écoute l'écoute pour
la liberté que ça là et non pour haïr ou
pour dire je pensais pas qu'il pensait
ça c'est oui il y a des bouts de sérieux
il y a des bottes qu'on déconne aussi là
c'est vrai que fait le tri dans le fond
vraiment
de l'histoire puis après seulement qu'il
écoute le choix de l'écouter exactement
Mike c'est comment se comporter mais
mais dans le code et puis ça c'est Mike
c'est souvent Patrick Huart à ce jeu-là
mais quand tu fais un émission de télé
c'est que tu vas dans la tête en visite
chez les gens mais quand tu es dans ton
podcast quand tu es sur ta 5
c'est chez nous chez nous là les bottes
vont pas dans le bain puis on boit même
si 10h du matin c'est ça c'est le même
ça marche chez nous la cloche
aujourd'hui c'est votre podcast la clé
des gens qui vont venir rendre dans
votre univers taxi là immédiatement ne
le goût en plein milieu du podcast de
laisser un 5 minutes qu'on s'envole au
bar boire quelque chose pour rien on a
le droit c'est à vous autres mais après
ça peut-être
de 5 minutes avec personne autour de les
règles de chez nous on va pas 5 minutes
aujourd'hui je suis votre invité il
fallait que je me compare
comme votre invité comme tu veux c'est
vrai fais comme chez vous
mais c'est c'est
la première fois que j'entends ça puis
je trouve ça fait vraiment du sens là
puis la réflexion là de on choisit un
peu les invités qu'on voulait qu'on
recevait permis on choisit selon le un
peu selon le nom la personne permet on
s'est dit on reçoit qu'on veut c'est
notre podcast mais oui il faut savoir
qui on veut si on veut recevoir une
personne quatre fois de suite on va
recevoir quatre fois de suite parce que
nous intéresse ça nous tente de faire ça
il y a aussi il y a des fois tu as une
chimie avec avec quelqu'un comme moi je
vais peut-être pas la personne il y a
peut-être vous avez reçu des gens ici
plus connus que moi mais aujourd'hui
peut-être quand je vais sortir du paquet
j'avais une bonne chimique une chaise ok
mais moins connu que on s'en fout vous
vous êtes meilleurs quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui vous fournit c'est quand
même qu'on aurait Genève mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde n'écouterait
mais il fait juste du Riez non yes non
pas cool
mon on revient pas après le monde ne
reviennent pas ils vont dire ah c'est
c'est pas capable de rattraper quand
même épique genre on a bouquet pas même
pas notre premier podcast en anglais
mais pourquoi non mais tu comprends des
fois il y a des affaires qu'on peut pas
tu sais il y a un coup de chance un coup
de lotte tu sais que c'est quoi mettons
les bookings de ses côtés tu parlais de
de chimie peut-être trouver comme le bon
trio c'est quoi mettons les bookings de
mettons les dernières années que tu dis
ça c'était une bombe ou King c'était un
bon match ça fait un podcast incroyable
mais je veux dire quelque chose ça
dépend
parce que tu étais chips sont en
fonction des gens qui t'écoutent c'est
si aujourd'hui la majorité des gens qui
écoutent votre podcast c'est des gens en
20 et 30 ans il y a aucune idée je suis
qui tu sais faire qu'il l'écouteront pas
l'épisode de cette semaine tu comprends
ici c'est des hommes dans ou peut-être
moi je vais attirer une nouvelle
clientèle là-bas on va dire je les
écoutais pas ces deux-là mais je vais
aller écouter Michel là ce podcast là
tac c'est c'est quoi un bon booking mais
c'est des booking surprenante tu
t'attends pas c'est aussi pour pas si je
vais donner un exemple on a reçu les
gars de la poche bleue il était passé si
tu ces deux joueurs d'Orchies depuis
l'âge de 14 ans qui a un agent je sais
même pas si on fait de la nourriture des
20 dernières années qui sont drôle sont
fin sont sympathiques tu vois qu'il y en
a vécu des affaires moi le sérieusement
les gars de la poche bleue j'ai été
surpris parce que c'est un bonbon King
les gars travaillent tout le temps
ensemble mais là ce serait le fun de
séparer mettons les deux gars puis
mettons mettre je n'ai pas Mathieu
Pepper avec Mathieu Maxime Lapierre je
sais pas genre un aussi bon podcast
c'est comme si c'est nous deux on
connaît toutes nos histoires avec
mettons aussi l'histoire de il faisait
ça beaucoup mais c'est quand même un
conduit la foi qu'avec sa coca et vous
là
c'est ça c'est c'est malade d'autres
bons booking tu sais qu'il y a des fois
il y a des enfants tu t'attends pas puis
il y a quelqu'un qui disait je vais le
faire avec telle personne puis on reste
surpris là quand c'est tout le temps
c'est qu'est-ce qui est triste les
booking qui te surprennent c'est sûr que
tu t'attendais qu'elle est
parce que c'est souvent une phrase que
je répète en maths c'est moi dans un
année j'ai 52 semaines à bouquet 52
semaines x 2 humoristes ça fait 104
humoristes taxi en or 20 % on le voit
dans toutes les podcasts au Québec on le
voit ceux qui tirent plus que ceux qui
tire moins là mais mettons il y a un
risque 80 dans l'année que
techniquement c'est pas des bons invités
de podcast je te dis pas que son mobile
je te dis juste que c'était pas le
médium qui leur faute
je te dirai c'était un gars comme
Stéphane Rousseau c'est tout le temps
machine de combat à avoir ils vont des
chances et ils vont là mais lui raconte
sa vie banale t'es fortunes ils vont
c'est c'est super intéressant c'est
qui qu'on a eu dernièrement il y en a
plein de filles qui sont c'est chaque
fois qu'on a
Jonca si Marlène Jonca est punchy
Christine morancier de ce fait longtemps
là j'ai le bout de bois Christine c'est
mon autre Grenoble si je trouve ça drôle
si ça a pas de sens l'épisode avec avec
Just A by là il y a l'épisode où note
just a bye
[Rires]
je regarde moi j'ai pas le contact à
Paul de toute façon moi j'ai obtenu
prochaine game de pauvre je vais
demander s'il va venir faire ses courses
manger
super
on bordel mais c'est ça aussi le t-shir
je regarde dans les 5 c'est un nom qu'on
a eu dernièrement c'est un nom aussi je
voudrais avoir tout seul c'est comme
étant un exemple à sous écoute j'ai reçu
clos meunier avec Yvon Deschamps mais
j'aurais voulu avoir ils vont avec moi
puis Claude avec boîte on s'en fout le
titre tu comprends mais c'est c'est des
Mons de l'humour
un autre épisode où j'adorais puis que
ça a pas fait des gros chefs à vous
écoute j'en parle souvent parce que ça
peut être un jour je vois l'exorciser là
mon ordi François Pérusse François
Pérusse a travaillé sur Love des Beatles
c'est le soleil il y a eu les bandes des
Beatles chez eux pour faire du découpage
dans les [__] débiles j'ai entendu les
conversations de Paul mécanis et John
Lennon and help il est des beat
lui le Québec ouais
c'est une légende qui vient
moi je pensais que ça allait faire c'est
combien de gens des références de
François Perrier
mais c'est pour ça que je te dis mais je
comprends pas pourquoi que mettons paper
puis moi ferait des meilleurs chefs
le point mais c'est vrai que c'est des
fois des fois c'est ça des fois c'est le
temps
des gens comme ça nous autres aussi des
fois on a du monde que on fait genre my
god là
pour nous autres c'est énorme puis le
monde ça passe au dessus de leur tête
mais je pose une question vous autres
parce que
moi aussi pensez-vous que quelqu'un que
vous on connaît mais qu'on le voit tout
le temps comme là je vise personne j'ai
pas écouté rien mais mettons chroniqueur
sucré salé puis on le voit dans tu es un
petit showter les bons on le voit un peu
partout tu penses-tu que ça intéresse
moins les gens vu que les gens qui
consomment ce genre d'humain là il
consomme à la télévision enfin pour
qu'il viendrait réécouter d'autres
choses de plus ici quand à toutes les
stages je sais pas ce qu'on voit ce que
je disais comme moi la seule place tu
peux voir Michel grenier au Québec
[Musique]
j'aime ça Michel qu'est-ce qu'il dit ou
j'aime ça comme à Michel parle allô
coucou c'est que ça se passe
comme je me fais rare est-ce que je fais
des bons chiffres pour que tu me vois
pas partout c'est sûr que la rareté
c'est c'est sûrement d'emballage du
monde que tu vois partout parce que
mettons c'est des animateurs efficaces
mais
ils font très bien leur travail mais tu
te tue envie d'en savoir plus mettons de
savoir l'histoire de cette personne-là
peut-être pour puis tu sais toi j'ai
l'impression que tu allais faire un
podcast tu vois bien performer parce que
tu comprennes
tu gravites dans cet univers là le monde
qui consomme les podcasts c'est un c'est
une niche aussi on a reçu du monde
mettons des musiciens il faut le connu
tout le monde connaît mais tu es en
termes de sud de chiffres de pour un
podcast pas malade parce que c'est comme
pas le médium avec lesquels sont
associés habituellement puis quel est le
monde qui consomme ça c'est peut-être
pas du monde qui écoute cette musique le
whatever mais je pense que encore là tu
l'as bien dit c'est que je sais autour
du monde du podcast mais mettons un
super musicien c'est cool mais dans un
podcast que les gens vont écoute juste
de pour de la musique je pense qu'il
ferait des scores de fou sûrement
qui fait des émissions puis tout c'est
le monde qui aime cette personne là puis
qui contribue à son
succès ou son film mettons c'est pas
c'est du monde qui consomme les médias
dans lequel il voit lui retire avec la
madame qui voit le jeu
noir ATV
la madame est pas sur un pop podcast ou
ce sport
salut tout le monde le connaît parce que
tout le monde connaît de Gino mais les
fans de Gino ils sont pas sur Spotify
transfert moins parce que c'est du monde
qui suivent pas les les médias dans le
fond puis le monde qui sont sur
justement c'est pour les faire à popote
écoute pas Salut Bonjour J'aimerais
savoir Gino
ça arrive quand même ça arrive des noms
à sous écoute c'est bien du monde des
fois sont juste pas l'eau au moment des
invités
faut juste relancer plus tard c'est dans
le sens que ce n'est pas le bon moment
pour l'artiste que vous voulez recevoir
l'inviter que vous voulez recevoir des
fois c'est juste c'est pas le bon moment
c'est juste ça si moi je lance une
invitation à Fred Pellerin puis son
horaire est toujours trop chargé
oui oui ok mais il y a peut-être pas
dans le coin ici on fait des choses
[Musique]
qui font comme tu fais plein d'autres
podcasts pourquoi tu fais pas le mien
ben je peux pas toutes les faire deux
top huit de code d'écoute
c'est les podcasts la raison pourquoi on
est tous à 99 % reçoit nos invités
gratuitement c'est qu'on a pas les
moyens des pays à boire de l'argent on
les payerait mais on lui a pas l'argent
donc tu penses-tu que il va partir du
centre du Québec pour venir ici pour
gratuit pour puis aussi dans un podcast
je l'ai déjà dit mais
si tu es une mauvaise personne fais pas
de podcast parce qu'en deux heures ça va
sortir ça va sortir fait que tu es en
train de nous dire quand les branches
fait le prélerens c'est un truc
[Rires]
trouver que tu étais sous écoute avec un
peu dans le c'est sûr que ça va paraître
ça serait malade moi ce Go là sur
podcast c'est la peu importe qui peut
leur recevoir au Québec peu importe qui
veut le recevoir ou pourrait ou serait
capable de maintenir cette conversation
là ce serait moi je pense ce serait un
podcast incroyable je l'ai vu une fois
venir faire une conférence dans un de
mes cours à l'université où est-ce que
tu es pas en contexte de compte de
compte puis de son compte qu'on connaît
puis il était pareil mais il parlait de
quelque chose qui avait jamais dit avant
tu racontais quelque chose qui était une
histoire dans sa vie puis la Comté comme
si c'était un conte de satellite klaxon
je trouve que dans un podcast de deux
heures sans montage c'est que le doit
être vu Téléjournal c'est un moment
incroyable tu sais mais attends ça c'est
sûr ça serait débile mais je pense que
les artistes de plus en plus je te parle
peut-être pas là mais tu dis ça ce
serait débile des voir mais je pense que
le podcast va devenir va faire partie de
la stratégie de l'artiste sûrement quand
ils vont sortir des albums des trucs
comme ça définitivement
ce qu'on soit surtout des humoristes pas
que je me dis tu sais je comprends là tu
veux venir puis aussi c'est ça qui est
mauvais c'est que mettons l'auteur d'un
livre il peut pas être puncher mais moi
c'est deux heures de tête de l'alcool
enfin que une fois que tu as raconté les
péripéties de Marianne sur une plage
avec Hugo
on fait quoi un an 45 qui reste c'est
pour ça c'est pas une chaîne Netflix
c'est sûr que
ça que ça soit écrit dans le plan
nécessairement sûr que mettons pour un
humoriste pensez à sous écoute c'est un
bon step c'est rendu Juste pour rire des
années 90
des fois puis ça c'est le problème qui
vient avec ça c'est que puis on a parlé
le chemin l'autre fois avant le notre
table ronde mais
ça fait ça crée un
problème une pression l'artiste arrive
sur stage tu sens qu'il veut puncher tu
sens que c'est off puis ça ça backfire
un peu dans le fond là dessus souvent
moi j'essaye de répéter puis en même
temps je peux pas dire aux gens comment
qu'ils doivent se sentir mais souvent je
répète aux gens là il y a pas de stress
là tu es assis écoute ça fait juste
jaser essaye pas d'être drôle soit drôle
essaie pas d'être intéressant soit
intéressant
c'est souvent sur Macron dans des
sous-écoutes il y a du monde mais ça
intéresse personne sur mon champ oui oui
je veux savoir justement
expose c'est comme moi si je suis vos
réseaux sociaux je le sais déjà mais
quand tu me parles un bataille moi je
m'a toujours deux doses
je veux ça mais c'est super intéressant
moi j'ai des taux ce matin pour toi
c'est pour ça que tu publies pas mais
pour les femmes c'est ça qui veulent on
peut passer tu sais je pense que
James
et puis lui tripes ses abeilles puis je
pense qu'il fait son miel
de ses abeilles puis passionné puis tout
puis genre tout le fucking chanteur de
Metallica genre une des plus grandes
légendes de la musique
que je colle m'a changé la musique
mais c'est quand même malade le pire
c'est qu'il est tellement passionné puis
connaissait
que même si parce que tu mets ton titre
intéressant parce que le gars il passe
il connaît son affaire justement il est
passionné enfin quelqu'un passionné de
quelque chose puis aussi c'est quoi
toutes les fois que Metallica est en
entrevue c'est ça la force du podcast
aussi toutes des fois mettre hélicat en
entrevue c'était on est à Tor
un nouvel album c'est toujours les mêmes
collègues de questions plus quand tu
vois à quand ton prochain show
si la première fois que vous venez cette
critique Google tabarnaie s'il y a de
quoi que ça vient mais c'est sûr que je
trouve word aujourd'hui c'est que les
gens j'ai trouvé paresseux
en un clic on peut s'envoyer n'importe
quel information beaucoup d'affaires
je trouve ça tellement hâte il y a pas
un show en Amérique du Nord qui peut se
vanter d'avoir reçu pendant 45 minutes
parce que personne restait penser ça le
truc c'est une des forces de Rogen aussi
puis à tort parce que des fois il est
tellement dans la conversation du moment
présent mettons il va genre le Jamel te
parle d'abeille puis l'autre différence
à qui on parle d'abeille en 45 minutes
tellement que tu poses pas des questions
tu sais que tu aurais eu l'occasion de
faire devant toi il y a certaines
questions que tu as envie de poser je
pense arriver que le gars de Twitter
avant avant qu'il a une masse Twitter il
y avait comme une polémique qui venait
de se passer puis il était tellement
intéressé juste par le une conversation
banale qui a comme proposé il y a pas
parlé de la polémique puis le monde
était quand même genre tu as pas parlé
de polémique
votre job c'est de me rendre à l'aise
parce que moi je connais du monde puis
après ça c'était gens-là bonsaï school
leur podcast I will vol fight il te
laisse faire ce que tu veux j'ai parlé
d'abeilles pas c'est parce que là c'est
James etfield mais à mon année ça va
être quelqu'un d'autre je te donne je
suis un exemple disons qu'on voulait
avoir ils vont des chats je reviens avec
l'exemple devant des gens ils demandent
pour la première fois qu'il est venu ont
réussi à avoir ils vont deux heures pour
jaser après ça l'année d'après ils vont
rappeler je peux ils vont des champs je
peux te faire sous écoute
et oui bon mais parce que mais ça
pourquoi on l'a laissé José
des portes pour entrer dedans pour que
tu puisses y aller ou que comme qui
clairement ça se passera pas aujourd'hui
des fois on le sentier des choses que
peut-être que cette question là en ce
moment ça serait oui ou des fois de son
invité genre vraiment comme l'autre jour
on a reçu tu sais Geneviève Jean son
mettons oui mais tu es tellement ouverte
tu étais tellement genre à disait tout
faculté c'était comme c'était pas gênant
de poser des questions vraiment dans des
détails vraiment quand même vraiment
personnel ça devait être intéressant
c'était vraiment malade mais genre
c'est peut-être pas l'inviter c'est moi
je pense l'inviter peut répondre à
n'importe quoi c'est juste la façon de
le poser je pense pas qu'il y a il y a
je pense pas qu'il y a de réponse
stupide il y a des questions
il faut que tu amènes ta discussion tu
peux même dire que tu es à l'aise puis
on est là justement la magie du podcast
on a du temps ça on n'a pas un
chronomètre présentement qu'il faut
qu'on libère le studio c'est s'il y a
une question on va arriver à m'emmener
ça tombe sa table il y a aucun problème
dans José non c'est ça c'est sûr c'est
pour ça que tu es souvent je te demande
mais tant que les affaires qu'on veut
parler ou il y en a quatre ans c'est
cool parler de ça à l'aise
juste faire parler de Jérémy pendant 2h
c'est sûr parce que c'est ça c'est ça
qui est plastique entre 30 ans de
carrière tu te parler
aussi c'est la façon que c'est c'est
traiter par les médias souvent tu fais
ça c'est pas tout à fait vrai c'est tout
tu connais la vérité c'est ça qui est
mauvais c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux sociaux les tiens on dirait que
ce que tu es puisque le monde pense que
oui le décalage
solide j'ai le meilleur exemple la
semaine passée
je savais que ma blonde en voyage puis
là j'ai parlé j'ai dit j'ai fait quelque
chose avec ma blonde
des podcasts et c'est tout ce que j'ai
dit là il y a une éditrice de
narcissique m'écrit rap on fait un
article parce que tu as parlé du fait
que tu es en couple maintenant sur le
podcast et que sa république est-ce que
ça tente de commenter j'ai dit genre non
j'ai rien à dire de plus j'ai une blonde
puis là c'est sur narcity c'est genre pH
Quentin en couple bla bla puis là en bas
de ça d'un commentaire il y en a pas eu
beaucoup tout le monde c'est encore il
sait avec raison moi je m'en callister
il y a du monde qui
qui est comment écrire c'est comme si
moi j'avais voulu que cet article sorti
comme si moi je voulais attirer
l'attention sur moi-même en disant en
écrivant narcissique ça vous tente pas
de parler du fait que j'ai une blonde
puis fait que le monde mais dans ce
monde-là qui ont pris le temps de
commenter ceux qui ont interprété
l'article de l'artistique comme si moi
je voulais cette attention là dans leur
tête moi je suis genre une horreur
attention qui veut des articles de
narcissique sur mon couple qui intéresse
personne tu sais que genre la perception
que ces gens-là ont moi versus ce qui
s'est vraiment passé c'est à dire je
fais ma propre shit puis il y a
quelqu'un qui décide pour une raison qui
me dépasse d'écrire un article sur ce
ben c'est complètement différent mais je
peux je peux pas croire qu'en 2023 il y
a encore des gens qui comprennent pas le
principe de clic-bate tu sais dans le
sens que toutes ces revues on va le dire
tout de suite là vos auditeurs c'est le
temps tout ce qui est Hollywood véhicule
toute seule il y a tel pot il sorte la
nouvelle avec un titre pour que tu
puisses cliquer dessus pour que tu
puisses aller consulter ce qui se passe
puis entre toutes du monde qui
connaissent la formule aussi pour aller
s'allume qui commence
par 30 ans je fais ça je vais vous dire
comment ça fonctionne juste pour le
domaine artistique donc chaque fois
qu'on parlait de Mike que ce soit dans
les médias cette année quand Mike veut
qu'on parle de lui il va il a été à Tout
le monde en parle il va ce qui ressort
de tout le monde en parle exemple ça
tout le monde en parle Mike drop et je
suis allé avec ma blonde en vacances
ça sort dans un joint Minecraft nouvelle
blonde on n'a pas appelé c'est juste que
dans l'entrevue
exactement il y a pas
si ça sonne pour tourner travailler ta
belle-fonte avec toi mais on n'a pas
changé de Némo ni toi non José du des
revues importantes il y a quelque chose
la raison pour qu'ils font ça mais ils
font des sous avec ça on se demande pas
pourquoi tu es la faire existe parce
qu'il faut de l'argent
j'ai un fils qui a 12 ans mais quand il
était un peu plus jeune papa a commencé
on fait un deux tu as fait là
c'est super ce que c'est bon non parce
que le premier a rapporté de l'argent ok
de lui parce que le 3 c'est un flop le
tour normalement mais c'est c'est tout
le temps de question d'argent
t'es pas besoin de l'écouter que souvent
mais il y en a d'autres là
c'est n'importe quoi mais on dirait que
tu restes scotché sur le n'importe quoi
c'est comme tu es trop n'importe quoi
pour que c'était avant n'importe quoi
que c'est l'humour
[Musique]
premièrement il y avait deux affaires
intéressants pour vous filmer ça part
d'une histoire un peu vrai
[Musique]
puis aussi c'est le dernier film de
Ready
pour faire la promo enfin il y a deux
faits intéressants par rapport à ce bleu
puis là d'une d'après moi dune 2 iris
d'actualité j'ai l'impression que ça
sent bien ça mais je comprends ce que tu
dis en général
mais je sais pas à quel point là 1 est
un succès énorme succès pour justifier
un deux là c'est comme un petit film
c'est toute mon petit film de
l'université qu'on voit c'est des
fraternités ça se passe du temps en
anglais ça c'est le fun d'avoir au
Québec c'est je trouve que
pour la clientèle sa vie j'imagine
c'était cool dans le temps mais vous
êtes de l'âge
puis il me semble que c'était comme une
rime mais personnellement je l'ai jamais
vu
les joueurs de hockey qui moi j'ai tripé
sur l'ancien compte puis toutes mes
amies joueurs de hockey et c'est pas
écoutable je peux pas écouter ça
tellement c'est mal représenté mettons
les scènes d'accident
parce que tu sais il y a dernièrement il
y a sorti une série haute démolition
c'est sur sur le milieu de l'humour
mais c'est n'importe quoi ouais mais
c'est parce qu'ils prennent tout ce
qu'il y a dans cette série là c'est
arrivé mais pas même personne
le gars qui trompe et le gars qui
devient coach mais le gars qui était
changé puis le gars qui devait faire les
mêmes personnes
qui est arrivé dans leur séquence moi je
suis sûr que c'est vrai probablement
mais tu peux pas avoir un personnage qui
rentre juste d'un épisode pour se
suicider exemple pour monter c'est comme
dans des émissions justement die school
comme dégracy le toutes les drames qui
arrivent à travers toutes les toutes les
écoles secondaires des États-Unis au
complet ça arrive dans la même école
exactement tout ce qui se passe dans une
affaire et ça en général on connaît un
peu les codes les populaires tout ça
mais c'est juste qu'ils font avec 30
secondes dans telle ville et quelqu'un
qui péter le mec s'est fait tatouer ok
on va le mettre dans notre série puis tu
avais Drake
classique
de Grassis
c'est sûr que des affaires là-dedans qui
me
trouve ça reflète pas la réalité c'était
surtout c'est moi le métier que je
connais une réalité mais qui est pas
représentatif
c'est comme le gérant qui vaut chaud de
l'école puis qui fait des câbles des X à
faire de ceux qui veulent pas ça fait
longtemps moins je les appelle chez eux
non non mais je vois je vois brûler leur
pain moi
sérieusement oui quand on regarde une
soirée de l'école la semaine passée ce
soir là ce 5 minutes là il y a déjà je
vais ah cette personne là je l'aime oh
c'est un peu moins en général le
spectacle tu es toute bon mais c'est
normal que je dis numéro préféré des
numéros
mais je fais pas des cœurs autour de la
face du monde ça se fait pas sur j'en ai
vu des choses de l'école de l'humour
ok peut-être ça s'est fait une fois puis
l'ont mis en série peut-être
façon grossière un travail
d'appréciation d'artistes
en général c'est moi je te conseille une
série sur mon milieu c'est juste la
première affaire c'est la deuxième
affaire c'est le le tableau qui dépeint
des producteurs c'est oui il y en a qui
sont sketch on dirait moins aujourd'hui
puis en même temps mais c'est ce qui me
fatigue le plus c'est que les moldus
vont croire c'est ça que c'est ça
que c'est que ça ouais parce que le
milieu de l'humour a eu un mauvais râpe
dans les dernières et dernières années
avec ou sans raison
avec raison c'est un monde c'est le
milieu de l'humour ça a été un monde
très masculin c'est le langage était
très
je trouve que c'est avec raison puis ça
prenait ce genre d'en faire là fait que
moi je suis 100% d'accord avec la façon
c'est pas la façon mais de la façon que
ça a été fait c'est-à-dire de dire il
faut surveiller ça change ça change pour
que ça change ça pour ça d'accord avec
ça puis euh mais ce que je trouve triste
là dedans c'est que pour monsieur madame
tout le monde il commence mettons 12
humoristes quand tu dis qu'il y en a
cinq ce sont votre panier autant la
moitié des humoristes non excuse là
parce que l'école de l'humour fait ses
35 ans mais 12 humoristes par année tu
es rendu à 400 le fait comme un cadeau 4
mais il y a sûrement 10% des endroits
des plombiers qui sont
problématique puis 10% des avocats qui
sont problématiques c'est juste que
comme c'est un milieu public encore ça
revient à toi qui appelle le tu te
rappelles quand même pensé que là j'ai
appelé la cité la semaine passée parce
que que ce soit être vu
mais c'est parce que tu as le goût de
vivre ta séparation qui aura lieu
peut-être jamais mais devant tout le
monde c'est ça ton but mais c'est pas ça
non c'est pas ça la réalité
mais ça me fait ça me fait ce qui me
fait rire un peu là dedans c'est qu'on
devrait être à l'étape de notre vie
c'est les humains depuis 10 ans là tu as
pas d'excuses d'être un con parce que
tout ce Google c'est toutes les langues
dans ton téléphone je peux arriver à
maman un allemand puis dire par
là-dedans oh le café le plus proche est
au coin de la rue je le dis là tu as pu
d'excuse c'est moi je parle 180 là je
peux savoir tout sur tout je peux
visiter l'eau va si chez nous de faire
plein d'affaires donc je trouve ça je
trouve ça triste que les gens croient
encore
ce qu'on écrit dans ces magasins
je contais des gens québécois ça parle
autour de moi mais j'espère que les gens
qui l'écoutent l'écoutent pas c'est ça
reste une fiction ça reste que
tabac tout le temps plus épais parce que
tu cries tu crées une histoire oui
justement un homme l'unité personnage
puis qui a un arc focale du drame faut
qu'il y a des enfants
si la vie de chaque humoriste c'était ça
serait qu'on aime ça viser les
personnalités tu sais comme les
humoristes qui en ont eu les
influenceurs aussi en ont eu avec le vol
de Sunwing qui a juste trois personnes
dedans qui sont réellement mais c'est
toutes des influenceurs qui ont tout
acheté leur billard même chez eux toute
la gang c'est des influenceurs
finalement la date de deux personnes qui
ont en route 30000 abonnés toutes les
autres du monde c'est ça mais on aime ça
mettre un tag pour haïr du monde
ça c'est ça c'est clair ça c'est clair
les influenceurs il y en a une bonne une
bonne Go quand même là
mais c'est plus des créateurs de contenu
mais les gens le voient pas ça ils
comprennent pas c'est permettre en même
temps c'est plus des créateurs de
contenu il faut que tu cries beaucoup de
contenu pour justement avoir une
certaine influence je parlais à un gars
matin justement le gars il fait du vélo
c'est il fait du break de compétition il
y a vraiment au niveau puis il y a
réussi à se bâtir une une tribune assez
grande pour maintenant faire des sous là
avec ça sauf que pendant quatre ans il
crée du contenu à chaque semaine une
vidéo YouTube de tester telle affaire de
Bike tester
du contenu en tabarnak avant d'être
influencé
dans le fond influencer le monde a
acheté ce produit là que lui utilise
puis lui il s'est la raison pourquoi
qu'aujourd'hui les gens le croient c'est
qu'il y a pas beaucoup de jeter personne
j'étais tel produit c'est un influenceur
mais il est pas comme si c'est plusieurs
termes à influençable ça je pense que
c'est pas clair pour les humains ouais
pour monsieur madame tout le monde aussi
qui connaît pas ça qui est pas
nécessairement sur qui est pas sur
Instagram mais qui fait juste voir la
nouvelle radio cannes de gang de
Montrond sur Sunwing qui ont fait les
caves
ce qui me fait penser que est-ce que
est-ce que Mike a déjà fait de la
publicité
la vraie positionnelle genre moi je me
sens j'ai jamais vu ça à force sur rien
et j'avais mis ça passe sur rien non
super ce qu'il voulait pas ou c'est
parce que les compagnies voulaient pas
mettons
c'est un mix des deux si tu veux pas
t'associer à justement quand tu sais que
le public que tu vises pense que Mike
Yayi les handicapés une pub de charmen
mettons là
c'est pas vrai on s'est fait déjà
approché pour deux ou trois publicités
c'est vraiment c'est fait non non
non même un de mes exemples moi je me
rappelle ça me dérange pas d'en parler
parce que ça fait très longtemps c'est
arrivé mais au début des années 2000 il
y avait une compagnie de livraison de
poulet qui avait approché de livraison
une un restaurant qui reste du poulet
une route
la paire façon la plus de maîtrise c'est
une compagnie de livraison de poulet
ouais je sais bah t'expliquer pourquoi
je pense que je t'ai rendu dans ma tête
en avant c'était que il voulait dire que
le poulet était vraiment rapide au
niveau de la livraison fait qu'il
fallait que Max se déguise en poulet
jaune il court vers la porte puis rentre
dans le mur puis ils disent le poulet
est vraiment rapide ici
c'est ce qui commence à nous donner pour
un 30 secondes comme sur ma beaucoup
d'argent cette année-là je pense par
année je devais gagner 20 000 pièces
c'était 25000 pour 30 secondes
[Musique]
le poulet
parce que c'est arrêté le poulet un peu
comme François mascotte qui se fait déjà
deux fois quatre cinq ans qui fait plus
pendant Star War puis le monde n'appelle
en gros
mettons toute sa vie mais c'est vrai il
y a pas l'affaire
je vais tout le temps passer en
family-prix
il était comme déjà assez connu on
dirait pour ramener tu es pas connu
quand il commence à faire ça c'est là il
puis je laisse aussi pas non plus
les beaux malaises ça c'est un autre
affaire aussi si on t'associe encore à
quelque chose de il y a 6 ans c'est que
les gens
mais ou non c'est que les gens
considèrent que tu as pas à côté le film
de l'autre affaire tu es pas marqué
encore plus que ça va faire le thé après
là
n'apparition d'un baume à lèvres les
deux points 0 là dans l'espèce d'orgie à
fond ouais
mais tu vois quand Martin nous appelle
on embarque tout le temps ils ont été
collés ensemble
mais Martin aussi fait des affaires pour
Mike Brant ça devrait
être drôle
en plus cette année-là la courte du
déménager je pense 3 fois l'école de
l'humour parce que c'est une grosse
année
94 95 c'est une assaisonner
mais moi c'est que je suis le frère à
Daniel grenier des checks puis Daniel il
y a l'école l'humour
déjà
semi
pour les
mais c'est ça c'est c'était compliqué
puis j'ai rencontré mère Martin le
remporté toute cette année-là Guilhem
gay c'était tout le monde de cette
année-là c'était une grosse grosse année
les check thalot tout et puis c'est là
aussi tu es jeune
c'était vraiment jeune puis c'était bien
une fois ils sont à l'école de l'humour
vont se tenait tout tire on se tenait
tout le temps ensemble mon frère Daniel
y habitait avec perruids puis avec
Martin et Matt puis mon mec un bout de
temps restait avec un mot je reste avec
l'auteur qui écrivait pour main qui à
l'école puis Mike écrit avait son cours
c'était tout on était tout ensemble
c'est tout le temps puis on sortait
ensemble et on a la déplace ensemble
puis ça peut rester de même j'ai
rencontré Mike puis de fil en aiguille
cherche un gérant j'ai fait de bon on
peut le faire je peux le faire sans
attendre c'est un peu la même affaire
j'ai fait avec les chicken Swan c'est en
attendant puis toi
par intérim
aujourd'hui jusqu'à aujourd'hui que ça
fait 27 28 ans
aujourd'hui
c'est correct mais il y a plus
d'affaires qu'on sait pas si près
d'affaires que tu sais pas c'est ça qui
est bizarre c'est c'est les contrôles
vont tout le temps tu sais comme moi une
affaire qui me traumatise en tant que
créateur de conflit c'est que je trouve
ça plante exemple qu'au Québec ça c'est
quelque chose j'ai appris dernièrement
mais vous savez sûrement depuis plus
longtemps que moi Tik Tok paye pas au
Canada mais ça paye aux États-Unis mais
ça paye pas Canada après
mais ça je savais pas ça mais j'imagine
que quand tu étais un créateur Tik Tok
tu vas voir Canadiens qui ont tabarnak
que ça traversait la traverse ça c'est
si c'est à travers parce que là j'ai
entendu l'autre jour à la radio qu'à
partir du 24 du janvier 2014 c'est
l'état du Montana veut interdire le
TikTok dans
l'application carrément carrément si tu
es un provider d'application puis tu
l'as dans tes choix
je te barre j'imagine mon balai acheter
les les mais si ça si ça fait pas le
tour parce que je sais qu'aux États-Unis
c'est vraiment
en ce moment c'est en gros débat pour
les questions d'espionnage
aussi pour les jeunes
préférés tu dis ah c'est ça le métier je
veux faire mais si ça avait combien qui
en a pas versus
[Musique]
par je l'ai passé bien fait ok je
devrais faire si je devrais ça mais ce
thème question de moment de look de
charisme de Tia il y a tellement
d'affaires c'est que je trouve pour les
jeunes je trouve ça difficile puis non
seulement cet aspect là qui est tout à
fait vrai de comme d'aspirer quelque
chose que finalement tu t'aurais pas
mais il y a aussi l'aspect neurologique
de vidéo de à un pouce près de pouvoir
passer des heures déjà là dessus ça joue
sur comme le développement cognitif puis
sur les troubles de déficitations c'est
bien que ça servait ses affaires là les
études vont sortir éventuellement de
vous savez que j'ai au dessus de 10000
followers
on a dit non à pub de poulet pour 25000
le design
il mange des des aveugles et je fais
comme 300 pièces c'est des montants que
tu fais comme je dirais pas que c'est
bon du jus d'orange
ouais conduire un Homer on te donne 80
ben non c'est mais c'est des montages du
80 c'est pas vrai mais ça diminue les
tof mettons en 300
mais je dirais pas que tout est c'est ça
que je je trouve wild c'est que je
dirais pas que le matin que le jus c'est
succulent soit qu'elle cognac c'est
fantasme
peut-être de 18 ans puis là tu commences
à avoir un following peut-être que tu le
fais mais ton ce que tu trouves mais non
mais c'est ça c'est comme un 300 pièces
monsieur mettons je sais pas là pour toi
je sais pas le 300 pièces ça n'a pas
nécessaire
des fois je pense que ça représente mon
genre faire ta pause avec le jus
d'orange
je repars ça les affaires j'ai fait là
puis j'ai honte mais c'est à travers
tellement en fait que pour oh mais toi
tu sais ce que tu as fait maintenant
c'est ça exactement j'ai des affaires en
tête non non mais dans le sens beaucoup
de trucs que j'ai fait pour qu'ils
disent parce que les femmes on est
arrivé
j'ai archivé c'est photos là
mais genre pas gênant la photo comme tel
est pas gênante mais ce que je suis
genre le moment pour moi de faire ça
avec toi moi déjà ok prends une photo de
moi
un maillot de bain genre parce que là
j'ai reçu un nouveau maillot puis le
chewing club avec un maillot puis
leur prend la photo plus va voir la
photo leur prend la photo plus du monde
qui te check plutôt
fermer le piège ça vaut pas ce moment ce
que je vis maintenant j'ai envie au
final si c'est Bella
dans le pire moment qui payait mon loyer
mais alors des fois ça me gratte en
dessous de la peau quand je repense à
des affaires j'ai fait si Elon Musk
allait faire des photos de maillots pour
1000 pièces là je serai choqué mais toi
au moment où tu le fais j'avais besoin
puis les gens sont un autre affaire
aussi que je trouve triste aujourd'hui
on brise beaucoup de mythes autour des
des gens peuvent croire les gens pensent
à minutes que tu penses à télévision tes
multimillionnaires ouais lui il doit
être riche sur Tik Tok il y a tant de
following ça paye pas au Canada
et est-ce que c'est en prenais justement
un maillot à gauche un jus d'orange à
droite quand je réussis de
parce qu'on s'entend si tu fais quatre
collabres dans le mois ça paye ton
logement puis tu apparaisse de métro
mais dans le Québec là il y en a il y en
a moins que sur deux mains tu sais qui
doivent bien vivre que de ça il y en a
qui ont fait des compagnies externes ça
je calcule pas ça là mais juste des
collaborations puis des comme lifestyle
tu dois en avoir max 10 fait que genre
il y en a plus que 10 qui ont donné
l'impression de vivre ça mais il
travaille son barman au Saint-Denis
qui font de la pub je veux dire avant
tu vois un comédien ou un humoriste
faire une pub tu dis pas genre ce qui à
moi qui est vendu moi qui fasse le
poulet qui rentre dans la porte tu dis
pas jean-christ devant Dieu montrer que
genre comme un step sur Instagram on
dirait qu'il est comme oui mais en même
temps c'est un problème
et moi maillot ferait me payer plus que
1000 morts moi maillot là ça coûte cher
s'il y a des compagnies de maillots il y
a pas d'école avec moi là
faut que tu
t'es pas en train de moi je pense que où
est-ce que j'aurai de la misère en tant
qu'influenceur c'est tenter d'influencer
des gens pour qui je sais que c'est
mauvais c'est de porter un maillot
non mais genre pas au tout des maillots
tu m'en parles tu comprends merci
c'est ça qui fait chier celui-ci
on va le moral c'est ça mais mais si tu
fais le maillot tu sais au moins ok
telle place je savais pas qu'il y avait
des beaux maillots comme ça je trouve ça
chill mais si tu étais en train de dire
si tu es en bas de 12 ans faisait la fin
si tu avais corrompu une certaine ou
aller chercher vers les personnes rien
de plus faible c'est quand j'ai des
personnes plus faibles c'est tout le
monde c'est faiblesse plus facilement
par les handicapés
les gens qui font qui les gains les gens
qui ont des problèmes de cannelés
j'ai tout le temps le goût de jouer
comment j'ai fait de l'argent sur Batman
le tu sais que du monde il faut incrusté
facile l'accès je vais aller je vais pas
me mettre personne à dos surtout lui là
mais ça me fait capoter de voir que
Georges s'associe à ça personnellement
c'est parce que il est très riche puis
encourage du monde à devenir PAF
peut-être qu'il peut s'éloigner
c'est vraiment une nouvelle tendance qui
vient des États-Unis moi je suis quand
même
le betting sportif là ça a vraiment une
réaffluence en ce moment aux États-Unis
ça devient vraiment énorme là de plus en
plus d'être légalisé le gaming en ligne
ce qui est sûrement vraiment
problématique pour des gens qui ont des
problèmes de jeu mais qui est aussi une
industrie
Callas lucrative aux États-Unis en ce
moment puis au Canada on voit que ça
commence à rentrer parce que c'est une
nouvelle façon de consommer le sport et
que les professionnels mettons ses
affaires-là tu sais Mike doit et d'où à
cause il doit parier sur duos
parce que chaque fois que tu mets un 20
pièces mais donc tu as pas de problème
de jeu moi c'est ça moi je parie sur les
game de football
américain à chaque semaine je commence
la saison avec 100 pièces puis je remets
jamais dans le compte fait que je fais
juste à jouer ce que puis ça fait que
chaque partie tu mets un vin et ta gamme
tu l'écoutes même si tu as aucun aucune
équipe pour qui tu prends aucun joueur
que tu aimes tu n'as rien c'est juste
comme tu es là sur ta chaise c'est
trilant pendant deux heures et demie tu
sais que fait que je comprends la traite
du gaming en ligne après ça
j'imagine c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
réglementé puis c'est aussi dur de
d'avoir des des trucs comme ça comme
Batman qui arrive puis un année on
pouvait gager sur le galop les oliviers
ah ouais avec le Québec sur qui a les
gagné
puis ça ça va être difficile parce qu'il
y a des juristes d'un jury
tu es dans le jury mais tu peux dégager
moi j'avais gagé mais moi j'étais pas
dans le jury moi j'ai gagé tu sais tu
peux agir sur 1 4 5 humoriste et que
c'était facile c'est quand tu suis
c'était ça je savais qu'il allait gagner
je pense j'ai mis mes dons
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est une nouvelle
tendance puis c'est oui Mike you moi
aussi si je suis allé avec j'avais été
main une année à puis on avait su qu'un
tel allait gagner un tube on a gagé ont
un combat du FC le dernier combat de UFC
pas le dernier l'avant-dernière
on est allé voir Georges mais dans la
sous-cartes on avait su qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui était béton quatre contre
un on a gagé tout de suite on a fait
plein ah ouais vous aviez appris que
vous aviez appris derrière les banques
par l'autre que l'autre est blessé
puis des fois d'un sport de combat aussi
puis ça c'est on en parle vraiment pas
assez parce que moi aussi je suis là
c'est pas un combat mais des fois
mettons le il faut en venir du monde du
Mexique pour roder un gars
ils vont faire venir un gars de
l'Amérique latine où se faire pour se
faire défoncer c'est une pratique
courante en boxe quand même des fois tu
vois ça donne l'argent mais c'est sûr
les autres ils se font venir ils savent
qu'ils vont se faire péter et puis leur
rôle c'est un peu de se faire péter mais
en même temps c'est comme voici de
l'argent pour payer de la pour toute ta
famille dans prochaine année là tu sais
qu'il vient de se faire péter en
Amérique du Nord ça c'est c'est pas
assez discuter je pense
[Rires]
un peu sur soi quand vous m'avez quand
vous avez déçu que je n'ai avec vous
autres aujourd'hui si tantôt te dit
laisse passer longtemps enfin c'est quoi
les questions que tu voulais savoir
est-ce une bonne question qu'est-ce que
tu demandais sur moi de fantastique
c'est cool les secrets qu'on veut savoir
que tu es jamais dit nulle part tu sais
qu'en maillot il faudrait me payer cher
pour voir ça c'est sûr c'est sûr là ça
deviendrait je pense que de 5 mois
Michel à cache-toi Michel
mais je sais pas si vous avez des
questions parce que tu sais quand tu
reçois un invité vous vous préparez vous
un peu ou vous vous dites
ça ça ou vous allez vous googler sur moi
puis vous êtes en tabac j'en auraient
pas suivi invités
que tu as fait j'ai check-initi ça fait
longtemps que je suis chez qu'est-ce que
tu fais et puis tu sais je te connais
effectivement
c'est des fois on reçoit des sujets bien
pointu sur des sur l'actualité de la
femme faites-le on va se préparer plus
mais on peut avoir d'un imbécile mais
moi c'est en train de dire que je suis
une personnalité pas actuelle ça vous
dit non mais c'est en fait on a deux
types de podcasts on a les podcasts où
est-ce que on traite un sujet puis il y
a les podcasts où est-ce qu'on reçoit
quelqu'un OK puis là quand on reçoit
quelqu'un souvent si on genre comme on
le fait
évidemment il y a des coupes d'affaires
de la la vision toute seule
qui était en cours mais je vais te
demander en fait j'ai fait de la joke
tantôt mais ça on est rendu où avec
l'idée parce que quelque chose qui nous
intéresse nous aussi spécifiquement
c'est c'est
[Musique]
c'est sûr et certain que les podcasteurs
comme ça a toujours partie petit puis du
jour au lendemain on a vu des podcasts
arriver puis repartir si je fais un
jeune pensée présentement pour trois
bières tu sais qu'il y a comment qui est
un espèce de précurseur
et là il y a très longtemps mais si ils
ont toujours eu une armée fidèle mais
pas assez pour enlever faut que je pense
que eux si tu arrives avec un tu dois me
payer UDA il y aurait qu'à porter mais
il continue quand même à livrer leur
podcast pendant au dessus de 10 ans là
c'est pas que des podcasts comme ça qui
essayent qui essayent qui essayent qui
grimpent qui grimpent mais ça marche
trop jamais puis il y en a d'autres ça
va marcher un bout ça va droper mais
quand ça va droper tu veux continuer
capable de le faire ce qui fait que même
si sous écoute c'est le plus gros
podcast québécois
j'arrondis parce que c'était
mettons que c'est celui qui a le plus de
code d'écoute mais l'équipe de sous
écoute c'est Mike moins
Yann qui réalise
je fais de la gérance d'artistes le
lundi là j'ai pas le temps de faire
comme Aya finalement c'est qu'on a eu
c'est pour moi c'est anne-Élisabeth
bossé au cas il y en a qui leur faut
changer mes contrôles des fois je
l'envoie à son agent le l'argent pour
une répond pas crime UDA m'a envoyé un
grillé
j'ai pas la structure il y a aucun
podcast québécois c'est de ne pas
comprendre le podcast québécois que de
penser que c'est possible de passer que
c'est possible il y a peut-être une
solution qui pourrait être réfléchie
mais dans la formule que tu sais on
parlait tantôt tu sais parce que c'est
ça il y a des podcasts au Québec je vais
pas viser personne c'est mais je vois
viser des gens il y en a qui disent
podcast indépendant podcast
que tu reçois une somme de quelqu'un
pour produire puis le contenu la partie
pue je t'annonce que tu es pas un
podcast indépendant si tu me suis que la
publicité qui va sur ta création c'est
moi qui en poche
c'était pas indépendant indépendant
c'est nous
est-ce que c'est tellement nébuleux
c'est juste que je pense que ça prend
une discussion mais ça prend aussi pour
penser à une structure qui fait que
l'UDA toujours été d'habitude de traiter
avec la télévision donc en télévision là
je tenaise même pas si tu as déjà été
voir mettons je sais pas moi je dois
prendre telle tout le monde en parle tu
arrives sur le plateau aussi son 15 à
peu près une qui te fait signer un qui
dit petit quelque chose à boire l'autre
qui dit je vais être reconduire à pas
l'autre qui va te conduire de la porte
jusqu'au studio tu arrives au studio
dans nos quatre qui te mette un micro 8
qui te filme 5 veux-tu un peigne 6
c'est ça pour vrai
[Musique]
je trouve juste que c'est de ne pas
comprendre le média c'est de pas prendre
le temps de s'asseoir avec moi je
m'assoiserais pas juste avec sous écoute
je prenne sale rempli il faut que vous
soyez là faut que mais tout du monde qui
font ça par passion qui ont de un
auditeur à 100000 mais je veux qu'il
parle à chacun en disant toi c'est quoi
ton rêve mais moi je suis seul la
semaine je suis pompier volontaire dans
telle ville mais la fin de semaine on se
réunit moins people puis on tripe au
moins fait des podcast oui on fait des
podcasts c'est bien il y en a d'autres
aussi c'est comme si vous avez plusieurs
studios c'est le fond on peut se louer
un studio moi aussi je paye pour faire
un studio parapluie dans ma job depuis
cette semaine faut que je remplisse de
la paperasse pour
UDA bleu le gérant il y a pas reçu mon
courriel ça a Bancé de mauvaise bois
pour ça que je suis ouvert à une
discussion mais je peux faire à le faire
parce qu'une fois qu'ils vont être dans
sous écoute leur but c'est ça
moi c'est ça je me dis en plus parce
qu'en plus la complexité que ça ajoute
c'est que s'il rentre là il rentre c'est
genre il rentre avec ça
une fois qu'ils sont là mais là il
rentre avec le podcast de de deux
personnes aussi qui viennent au studio
qui est qui reçoivent la foi dans
l'année où est-ce qu'ils ressercevoir
François Lambert mettons mais que
François Lambert il y a eu des autres ça
leur coûte 300 pièces pour recevoir
Françoise
de le faire il faut qu'il ferme le
podcast ou qui reçoivent plus aucun
membre de l'UDA dans le fond ça va être
sur l'alternative c'est pas mieux pour
lui dire c'est qu'ils veulent que leur
monde travaille plus moi je t'en donne
du travail qui prend là le truc ça vient
tu de l'IDEO ça vient de membres idéaux
qui ont dit Hey petit checker ça me
semble être payé quand on va le saviez
demain ça vient de lui dire parce que
nous aussi
il nous parlait des des
membres idées qu'on reçoit sur le
Podcast exceptionnel
la grande majorité les trois corps des
personnes qu'on reçoit qui sont membres
des ha c'est eux qui écrit à la page du
podcast pour venir sur le Podcast
ils viennent en sachant très bien que il
y a pas de rémunération c'est l'exposeur
puis tout ce que tout ce que ça ramène
parce que aussi c'est bizarre mais ce
que les gens comprennent pas c'est que
moi si tu viens sous écoute là je te
remplis ta salle je remplis ta tournée
au complet ta tournée j'étais rempli ta
salle donc après ça mais je vois le
payer u da partout
c'est qu'à un moment donné aussi la
nouvelle façon d'être un artiste dans
les dernières années tu peux pas juste
style l'expression mettre ses œufs dans
le même panier là mais c'est ça le faut
que tu fasses un podcast là une story
puis là faut que ça sur Tik Tok le foot
faut que tu sois présent mais pour être
présent faut que tu acceptes que tu vas
là des places que ça donne ça puis il y
a d'autres places ça va te donner plus
mais j'ai juste 5 minutes avec toi donc
le dessin est
le dossier UDA si je t'aime attends sur
le si j'étais sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle ce serait fini ça serait
fini j'aurais pas eu le temps d'exposer
les points c'est c'est vraiment le fait
que les podcasts au Québec c'est des
petites équipes puis on n'a pas le temps
de gérer toute cette paperasse là mais
je comprends pas tu sais si c'est pas
une demande si tu es membre son
problème avec ça mais c'est quoi le
problème le problème c'est que en temps
c'est que sur présente des artistes le
tu remarques que tes artistes moi aussi
tu dis mettons ils Rousson le V2 fois
Rousseau à Tout le monde en parle c'est
tout le monde en parle puis Maryline
Jonca puis dans 4 podcast
ça reste un artiste pourquoi il est pas
payé au Cateau d'apparition fait deux
heures taxi en tant que je comprends que
les autres se questionnent et devrait se
questionner sur comment ça fonctionne la
réalité c'est souvent fait sur le coin
d'une table on s'appelle deux jours
avant il y a du monde qui nous cancelle
c'est soit il y a il y a plein
d'affaires qui arrivent moi je me suis
déjà fait canceller un sous-écoute là
j'avais un sous-écoute à 9 je vous
écoute à 6 puis pendant que tu es sur
scène sur celui de 6 à 7 mes invités
neuf mon cas c'est
puis le royaume font leurs affaires de
façon DIY avec aucun moyen mais je veux
dire cette distinction là entre la télé
et le web la ligne a encore une mais
plus flou qui a été puis à Wallet de
plus en plus je pense quand même puis
oui et non qu'est-ce que je veux dire
pourquoi c'est pour un Mr Bean il y a
100 000 wannabe qui gosse dans leur
sous-sol avec des Lego
plus c'est des podcasts après notre
terre son affaire comme là je vais pas
me tromper parce que Chuck va être
choqué donc moins mais c'est en deux
puis trois millions c'est c'est 80% des
podcasts 90 passe pas l'épisode 7 c'est
ici c'est qu'à un moment donné aussi
faut pas se faire
pour pas virer fou le tuer dans le sens
que c'est pour le ceux qui a du succès
on a tellement qui en ont pas c'est que
si tu rentres un contrat qui tombe pour
toi
c'est absurde
tu dis la ligne de plus en plus floue et
je pense tout le monde va trouver leur
compte un moment donné si tu as dit quoi
la raison pourquoi
l'avantage entre le web et la télé c'est
la télé tu as tout tourné ta saison
enfin que c'est dur de te réajuster en
cours de saison tandis que le web
ils ont plus réajuster c'est si
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui vous vous dites
ah si c'était mauvais on a trop parlé
avec Michel ok ça nous prendra un con un
timer là mettons on va le mettre le
timer tu comprennes on va améliorer le
produit mais on peut le faire dès le
prochain épisode vous pouvez être
meilleur dès le prochain épisode dans ce
quant elle est tout est captée puis
c'est beaucoup de salaire en dépendre
aussi le tien ouais mais tu n'empêche
que je veux dire par là c'est que tu
mettes même des trucs qui sont destinés
à la télé tu mets ton
d'après moi pendant plus de monde qui
écoute maintenant et que passion double
sur leur laptop que ça donne que alors
que ça passe à Télé à la télé puis si
mettons les pubs vont aller là
c'est sûr que maintenant tu es des gros
joueurs comme Québécois ont acheté des
podcasts j'ai l'impression que la
distinction qui était claire comme le
web c'est artisanal c'est indépendant
puis la télé c'est la grosse machine ça
sera plus nécessairement tout le temps
en vrai il va continuer tout le temps
avoir des indépendants sur le web mais
c'est
je me demande on va s'arriver à un point
où est-ce que parce que ça va être un
peu toute va un peu se mélanger
peut-être un peu toute la même affaire
puis là
un peu artisanal si à la grosse machine
derrière à Aigues que c'est fait que
mettons
des subventions mais moi je reçois pas
[Musique]
c'est
subventionné pour faire tes podcasts
mais tu es payé paye ton monde c'est
payé subventionné mais tu sais les 30
les 40 premiers épisodes non seulement
t'es pas payé mais son gênant je sais si
vous réécoutez vos ciseaux 30 premiers
épisodes ainsi qu'on était mauvais
j'espère vous vous trouvez mauvais parce
que si vous vous trouvez bon c'est que
vous êtes vous êtes encore mauvais
si vous écoutez les premières affaires
vous avez faites vous trouvez bon vous
êtes mauvais encore
c'est pour ça que tu sais c'est quelque
chose si je comprends qu'il faut en
parler parce que le web et le web c'est
le monde entier qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire c'est au Québec tu sais Mr Bean
c'est plus couteau au Québec que sous
écoute tu commences à appeler Mr Bean
Mr Bean
si je comprends la machine je suis pas
en train de dire c'est juste n'importe
quoi mais je pense que je pense que
l'affaire qui changera jamais puis ça va
être un changement de paradigme qui va
faire que ça sera je pense pas que ça va
se mixer tant que ça c'est la
distribution parce que la distribution
et pas lié c'est tu parles je vais
prendre l'exemple de Québécois québécois
en TVA effectivement tu peux distribuer
tout ce qu'ils font sur TVA puis si tu
as pas accès à une chaîne comme TVA ou
radio Cannes ou Oliver tu peux pas à la
télé mais pour le web tu vas pouvoir
être sur le web même si tu restes
indépendant tu peux pas faire une
émission de télé indépendante ça existe
pas
c'est ça
n'importe quelle plateforme où est-ce
que tu peux déposer un vidéo puis des
plateformes que tu peux déposer un vidéo
ils vont en avoir tout le temps qu'ils
vont être gratuitement être facile
d'accès puis aussi ce qui est ce qui est
dangereux c'est que si mettons l'idéal
est-ce que tout le monde va vouloir
légiférer sur est-ce que les
gouvernements vont vouloir légiférer sur
le podcasting tu sais comme là
aujourd'hui on a peut-être sacré cinq
fois dans l'épisode d'aujourd'hui ben là
on se fait on va essayer on va écouter
cet épisode là en 2e pour dire moi ma
cause que certains c'est là-dedans on va
être obligé de biper l'épisode
d'aujourd'hui des pays parce que Michel
c'est pas parlé
il y a tellement de choses à penser moi
je pense que c'est intéressant que l'UDA
c'est je trouve ça correct
s'intéresse à ça mais qui veulent faire
ils veulent nous traiter comme la télé
c'est là qu'on n'est pas de la télé mais
dans les faits ils ont su un certain
pouvoir de forcer qui que ce soit à
faire quoi que ce soit ou non tu es dans
le sens qui dit eh j'aimerais ça que
vous nous payez les membres puis que les
autres et il y a une d'une part qui va
aller
peut-être la seule pression qui peut
faire c'est décider de demander à leur
membre de poste présenter peut-être
là je me prononcerai pas parce que je le
sais pas
que je peux pas me prononcer mais ils
ont sûrement il y a sûrement quelque
chose c'est les unions ça a toujours
c'est une union
il faut que vous payez si tu dis non
qu'est-ce que tu fais
non mais non c'est ceux qui ont des
recours
pas assez loin dans le processus pour
savoir on va voir on va voir ça c'est
exact ça va ça va revenir
dans les questions
j'ai vu cette semaine que c'était fini
final
l'épisode de
non parce que tu sais il y a dit qu'il
arrêtait la poursuite c'est correct ce
que vous avez reçu une notice
publiquement ok moi j'arrête les
procédures sauf que officiellement dans
les faits sur papier c'est pas encore
arrêté
c'est ça qui est important
c'est une poursuite qui était importante
les gens du Canada ça c'est la Cour
suprême même pour Ben des gens ils
savent même pas qu'il y avait encore une
autre façon qui avait été demandé
[Rires]
pour ça je te dis c'est au moment qu'on
fait le podcast là c'est peut-être qu'il
y a reçu la lettre aujourd'hui mais au
moment que la vidéo était sortie elle va
pas
il y a rien qui est sûr encore
exactement
niveau pire ça serait bizarre qu'ils
disent ça puis que qui continue d'accord
avec toi le niveau payeur il y aurait dû
retirer puis après fallait la vidéo
sinon juste pour ce qui s'en vient avant
de te laisser partir là tu t'en vas là
tu faisais un rodage pour pierre-y
Pierre-Yves ce soir faire rodage fait
que je m'en bats voir ça voir c'est pour
son chaud sans belles enfin que il va
ajouter une nouvelle demi-heure enfin
qui est pris récré du stock et récré du
stock j'aime ça aller voir l'évolution
de toutes ces cas qu'un artiste est en
création j'aime ça suivre une fois que
le show roule votant sa route c'est le
fond puis de temps en temps je vais
aller dans certaines villes pour se
faire du fun mais c'est ça
oui mais faut pas qu'il m'écoute dans le
sens que j'ai des bonnes idées mais je
reste quand même
c'est comme vous autres là je pourrais
vous donner plein de bonnes idées mais
ça vous autres qu'il vivait votre
affaire votre podcast et puis c'est lui
qui monte sur scène c'est pour moi si je
peux avoir des flashs moi je pense plus
dans la oh ça j'ai mis ça ah ça c'est le
fun ça c'était la fin au sol public en
moins rimes mais moi je sais que c'est
bon c'est drôle enfin que j'en ai vu de
l'humour quand même j'en ai vu beaucoup
beaucoup tant que je pense j'ai une
certaine expertise là-dedans
pour ça que je peux donner mon feedback
c'est arrivé que je trouve des gags ou
des types de chaud des affaires là même
mais je suis plus quand c'est marketing
où trouver un angle où tu sais ou des
fois j'aime mieux quand tu penses direct
au point sauf que moi j'ai compris vers
où il s'en allait mais des fois tu as
besoin de donner la clé au public de
dire hey tu sais il y a des publics il
faut que tu prennes par la main là je
vais faire un gag de chien mais là avant
faut que je vous parle chien dans une
maison les murs sont mais moi je suis
comme autant dire ricochet mais ça a de
l'air que des fois je trouve tu
comprennes principes tu comprends pas
que le public a besoin souvent de se
faire prendre par la main un peu je dis
pas tant que ça mais un peu que j'aime
ça sur mes artistes qui sont justement
en rodage ou tiens chaud que chaque ça
va être plus difficile j'aime ça être
présent puis arrive il y a une ascension
phénoménale vraiment dans les années
c'est fou que son dernier show je l'ai
pas vu le voir mais apparemment que
c'est complètement
j'imagine ça doit être ça doit être
depuis le début depuis le début à
l'école de ouais et puis mettons
non non mais qu'est-ce que fait que lui
te fait ok il y a quelque chose de
spécial parce que clairement aujourd'hui
il s'approuve que moi c'est juste c'est
c'est une bonne ça va paraître bien sûr
mais moi quand je travaille avec les
gens là j'aime comme accent Orsay
sur scène oui ça compte là mais j'aime
l'ensemble de l'humain c'est un bon
humain puis moi je suis vraiment content
de travailler là c'est une bonne
personne qui dit des mauvaises choses
c'est du Congrès c'est qui arrive c'est
un bon humain il y a des bonnes valeurs
c'est mes articles sont toutes des
valeurs quand même commune puis j'aime
ce qui représente j'avais été le voir en
show plein de fois que j'avais été voir
l'école de l'humour j'avais j'allais
manger
je suivais je suivais je les boire
vraiment vraiment avant c'est moi de la
façon que je décide de travailler avec
un artiste si je vois le voir je veux te
voir comme un thé avec lui comme un thé
avec les femmes comme un thé sous comme
activité de bonne humeur quand même tu
es triste puis après ça on travaillera
peut-être ensemble une fois que j'ai
fait le tour des valeurs donc pour moi
c'était une bonne personne qui je
croyais j'ai même j'ai fait des
téléphones des fois là le lui dit cette
2 ans il va faire telle affaire j'ai
appelé des producteurs j'ai arrivé
factice c'est comme GG j'ai touche du
bois mais c'est tellement facile de
travailler avec lui c'est un gars
ultra talentueux c'est un gars qui a des
belles valeurs c'est un gars généreux
mais où on a toutes nos petites qualités
nos petites défauts mais honnêtement je
suis vraiment chanceux des gens avec qui
je travaille sur des bons humains
surtout du monde à qui c'est quoi tu
veux savoir si c'est des bons humains je
partirai en vacances avec toi tu t'es
galop pendant deux semaines bon et
facile
est-ce que je serai sur une plage à
Cancun
la réponse est avec Pierre-Yves pendant
sa tournée là que je suis monté à ALMO
jouer à des meurtriers mystères moi et
lui son équipe de tournage on sait tous
déguisé puis on fait des meurtres et
mystères on en refait un autre dernière
mèche descendait un matin pour faire un
meurtre et mystère une soirée riche
descendais à Saint-Georges de Beauce
faire des on faisait des concours de un
concours de magiciens donc fallait
épater les autres avec des taux de magie
je fais ça là je fais un adulte
mais c'était
c'est des amis ça avec Mike le monde en
Europe non on s'en va qu'en Europe il y
a une différence c'est Daniel c'est mon
frère c'est la classe cette semaine je
fais en moins cette semaine il sait pas
encore là
mais mercredi mais je vais aller avec
Daniel parce que je sais que le show va
être plus difficile enfin je dois y
aller c'est ce qu'on commande
publique c'est quand c'est ton public
qui ont acheté des billets sont déjà
chez vous mais quand tu t'en vas chez
quelqu'un plus corporatif c'est plus
difficile avec moi mes artistes c'est
tout du monde que j'aime qui ont des
belles valeurs des gens qui m'aident à
grandir qui m'aident à devenir meilleur
je le dis je le dis pas mal depuis le
début de ma carrière je suis pas un bon
gérant j'ai des bons artistes c'est ça
la différence ça j'ai vraiment des
bonnes personnes pierre-y viens
travailler ça c'est la base de quelqu'un
qui va réussir c'est quelqu'un qui
travaillait c'est ça c'est même chose
pour Mike même chose pour
de travail c'est bref je pourrais vous
en parler pendant deux jours mais quand
j'ai vu je le vois il y a même des gens
d'autres années de l'école de l'humour
cette personne-là ça va être fou c'est
mais c'est pas dit par je travaille pas
avec je posais chez moi je décolle la
semaine passée je t'ai dit ah ouais ok
ouais cette personne-là va être plus ça
cette personne c'est je suis capable de
supporter un peu parce que je fais ça
mais en même temps c'est 5 minutes je
peux pas juger quelqu'un juste sur cinq
minutes c'est pour ça j'aime aller voir
et revoir la personne
ça boucle la boucle avec ce qu'on
parlait plutôt au-dessus de
juste faire ce qu'on ce qu'on fait pour
les bonnes raisons puis le faire
honnêtement avec selon ses valeurs puis
si on fait ça le succès
puis juste de le faire peut-être d'avoir
le cas avant de place le faire
travailler puis la petite c'est une
belle morale pour ce pas
finalement vous m'avez gardé ici tant
que je fais pas ça exact
vous trouvez vous bien entouré oui
une pub de poulet je pense avec ça
mais ça dépendante
j'aurais un petit deux minutes parce que
je fais bon
un autre toujours je sais faut que ça
finisse là mais je vois je vois donner
un conseil un autre conseil parce que le
podcast finit dans l'armoire
négocier chaque contrôle comme si vous
aviez un million dans votre compte de
banque exactement
il faut toujours négocier pour toujours
si dans mon compte de banque aujourd'hui
je vais 20 millions je serai ici
je serais habillé probablement pareil
j'aurais pas le même short peut-être
mais c'est à peu près ça mais je réussis
quand même donc si toi tu dis moi ou
alors 10 millions dans mon groupe de
banque je serai assis ici peut-être à
bonne place c'est un conseil que mes
amis entrepreneurs Julien run sur son
podcast le journal d'un entrepreneur il
dit avant quand tu as une idée mettons
une idée de business le plat tu penses
tu veux te lancer en business le si je
te donne 500 000 pièces est-ce que tu le
fais demain quand même est-ce que tu
prends cet argent là pour lancer ta
business où tu fais genre ah je
regardais le 500000 si la réponse si je
garde le 500000 je peux pas business
pour pas business c'est le même principe
pour un projet comme un podcast si je te
donne une idée de podcast
en podcast quand même si la réponse est
non pas ton podcast exactement
puis médecine je payerais tu le genre de
tournée
dans 20 salles ça peut être la musique
chill
peut-être mettez moi je travaille
surtout tu es avec des artistes mettons
je fais de la tournée avec des
commitaristes ou je fais des je fais des
albums en studio avec des artistes et
puis
honnêtement en ce moment avec le studio
avec le podcast avec ceux je fais pas
mal juste travailler moi je comprends
puis mais tu fais ce que tu aimes mais
je fais ce que j'aime et puis là je fais
de l'argent vraiment je suis confortable
je visiter même que je fais tellement
juste travailler que cet argent là j'ai
même pas le temps de le dépenser tant
que ça ou je vois même pas vraiment dans
quoi que je le dépenserai facter je suis
un peu en fait je ferais probablement
exactement ma ma fac j'avais un million
dans mon compte ou non
[Musique]
chaque jour je fais ce que j'aime puis
date là vous êtes encore jeune tu sais
que
vous avez quel âge 30
31 je vois 32 cet été 32 qu'est-ce que
tu fais avec un million demain matin
[Musique]